um welcome everyone welcome back to uh
theory of
computation and
um
just to recap uh where we are we
um
[Music]
have been looking at time complexity and
space complexity
and um we
just finished
approving what are called the hierarchy
theorems uh which
you know in a nutshell basically say
that
if you allow the computational model to
have a little bit more resource a little
bit more time a little bit more space
then
you can do more things
so
with certain conditions
so we proved that
last time it was a proof basically by a
diagonalization i don't know if you
recognized the diagonalization there but
um you know when you're encoding a
machine by an input
and then basically running all possible
different machines that's essentially a
diagonalization
so
today we're going to
build on that work
to give an example of what we call
a natural
intractable problem
we'll say a bit more about what that
means
and then we're going to talk about
something which is a different topic but
nevertheless related
having to do with oracles
and methods which
may or may not work
to make
to solve the p versus np problem which
of course is a
big open problem in the field
okay
so
the time and space hierarchy theorems
because we're going to be using those
today
um they say that if you give a little
bit more uh space here so if you're for
space constructable functions functions
that you can actually compute within the
amount of space that they uh specify
um you can act you can show that the
things that you can do in that much
space
is probably
is larger than what you can do in less
space
and you have can prove a similar
slightly weaker fact about the time
complexity classes so what that means is
that the uh
these
classes form a hierarchy so as you add
more time or let's say in this case
space from n squared to n cubed to enter
the fourth you get um
larger and larger classes which i'm kind
of illustrating here by putting putting
a dot there which shows that there's
something that we know that's new in
those classes as you as you go up um
these uh these different bounds
and this is going to be true for space
complexity and it's also going to be
true for time complexity
um
so
and one of the corollaries that we
pointed out last time um is that
uh
p space
is a properly includes um
non-deterministic log space nl so n l is
a proper subset of p space so this stuff
in p space
that um
is not in nl and remember this notation
here this means proper subset
um
one of the things that uh
a follow-on corollary that we didn't
mention last time but that's something
that you uh you should know
is that
um the tqbf problem you know our
piece-based complete problem is an
example of a problem that's in p space
obviously but we know it's also not in
nl
and in order to get that conclusion you
have to
look again at the proof that tqbf is
p-space complete
and observe
that the reductions that we gave in that
proof
can be carried out not only in
polynomial time but they can be carried
out in log space
and therefore if tqbf turned out to go
down to nl
um then
because everything in piece base is log
space reducible to tqbf that would bring
all of p space down to nl
but that we just proved is not the case
so therefore tqbf could not be an nl
okay and we're going to be using that
kind of reasoning
um
again in this in this lecture
uh
so just a quick check in um
these are a few
more or less easy maybe more or less
tricky um follow-ons uh that you can
conclude from the
uh time and space hierarchy theorems
plus some of the other things we've
proven along the way
and so just uh as a check of your
understanding
maybe these a little bit on the tricky
side so you have to read them carefully
which of these are known to be true
um based on the material
that we've presented and this is also
you know just material that's
you know the facts that we know to be
true in uh complexity theory
um
some launch that poll
and just just check off the ones
that
we can prove
okay
i'm going to close it down
so please
answer quickly if you're gonna okay one
two three and
uh
okay
well the two leading candidates uh are
correct
so it's uh and the two that are the
laggards here are in fact the ones that
are not true
uh so a and a and d are not true
um based on what we know
and um b and c are true so let's
understand first of all a we know is
false
because 2 to the n plus 1 is just 2
times 2 to the n
and so that's just uh these two bounds
differ only by a constant factor and so
in fact they're the same complexity
class and so you don't get proper
containment for a so that that we
absolutely know is false
um
d
um
well if we could prove that
then we would have solved a famous
problem because we don't know whether
even p equals p space
so if p equal p space then certainly p
space would equal np which is in between
the two and so uh we don't know how to
prove p space is different from np as
based on the current state of knowledge
of the field
um so this would not be something that
we know to be true uh based on what
things we've said
now b follows
directly from the time hierarchy theorem
because 2 to the 2n
is the square of 2 to the n
and that is asymptotically a larger um a
significantly larger bound and so uh
um you can prove that um time two to the
end is properly contained it
properly contains time two to the n
c is a little trickier um
because
you need to remember savage's theorem
now savage's theorem applies to space
but you also need to remember that what
you can do in time in non-deterministic
time n squared you can also do a
non-deterministic space n squared
which then in turn you can do in
deterministic space n to the fourth
um
which is properly contained within space
n to the fifth
so you can prove that p space properly
contains
not deterministic time n squared
okay it's just a bunch of containments
there that's perhaps a little the a and
c are perhaps so in a sense it may be
the most tricky of the of this group
okay um
so
let's move on so we're going to
introduce today two new classes um
and you know i actually i want to go
back to here you know what are we trying
to
what are we going to be trying to uh
accomplish in today's lecture
so we're going to be looking at provable
intractability
so our
a problem being intractable for us means
it's outside of p
so
we can't solve it in polynomial time
for our
for our um perspective we're going to
call that an
intractable problem
now this problem over here
um that's sitting in time 2 to the n but
not in the smaller classes so this is an
intractable problem that's outside of p
um
but
this example of a language
if you remember how the um
time hierarchy theorem or the space
hierarchy theorem was proved basically
this language itself is not an
interesting language for other than the
purpose that it serves to be in that
class and not in a lower class
but it's not a language that anyone
would care about and it's not even a
language that is easy to describe
it's just a language that some touring
machine
um
uh decides whether a turing machine is
specially designed to have the property
that its language is at a particular
complexity level
but otherwise there's no nice
description of that language it's not
like a to the end b to the n or some you
know um
uh
equivalence of two dfas or something
like that
so i would say that
that language is in a sense it serves
its purpose but it's not a natural
language that you really care about so
one of the go the go one of the goals of
today's lecture is to give an example of
a natural language a naturally occurring
language in a sense
um that's easy to describe where you can
prove that that language is intractable
is actually outside of p
so that's that that's a bit of
motivation where we're going um so along
the way we're going to prove we're going
to introduce these exponential
complexity classes
exponential time and exponential space
which are um exponentially bigger
than
polynomial time in polynomial space
classes so it's 2 to the n to the k in
both cases two to the two to a
polynomial
and um
the first five of these classes l
through p space we've already seen and
exponential time and exponential space
extend
the containments that we've already seen
so
you have to double check that you
understand why p space
is a
subset of exponential time but that's
because that you know as we showed
going from space to time you can do that
with an exponential increase uh that's
the cost of the simulation
and going from time to space you don't
need any increase at all anything that
you can do in a certain amount of time
you can do in that much space
so anything you can do in a certain
amount of space you can also do an
exponentially more amount of time
okay so those were
simple theorems that we proved right at
the very beginning
now the hierarchy theorems allow us to
conclude some separations among these
classes
so we already looked at this one nl
versus p space
and we saw that because nl is
by savage's theorem in deterministic log
squared space which is properly
contained
in
polynomial space you get a separation
between those two classes um provably so
and for similar reasons polynomial space
to exponential space you're going to get
a
a separation from the space hierarchy
theorem and polynomial time to
exponential time you get a provable
separation
by virtue of the hierarchy theory
um
now we're going to define
complete problems for these two classes
exponential time and exponential space
so we have exponential time complete
it's going to be
analogous to what we
showed before
which is that
it's a member of exponential time
and every problem in exponential time is
reducible to it let's say in polynomial
time though it's not going to really
turn out to be matter it could be in log
space
um some simple method of doing the
reduction is going to be good enough
let's say polynomial time it's a typical
definition here
and the same thing for exponential space
complete
we'll say it's exponent it's exponential
space complete if it's an exponential
space and anything else in exponential
space is polynomial time reducible to it
okay now but the important thing
is that
if something is exponential time
complete
you know it's outside of p
for the same reasons we've now seen
several times
namely that if an exponential time
complete problem
ended up being in p
then
because everything else in exponential
time is reducible to the complete
problem they would also be in p and so
exponential time and p would be equal
but we just said they're not equal
because of the hierarchy theorem
so the logic is the hierarchy theorem
separates the class
and then the complete problem inherits
the difficulty of the larger class
so
the complete problem cannot be any lower
than the other problems in the class
because they're all reducible to it
okay um so the same thing is going to be
true for an exponential space complete
problem can't be even in p space
because exponential space and p space
are different
and and if it's not in p space it's not
going to be in p
and so in both cases
if you have a problem that's complete
for exponential space or exponential
time
we know that those problems are
intractable
and
our strategy then for giving a natural
intractable problem intractable problem
is to show it's complete for one of
these classes and it's actually going to
turn out to be an exponential space
complete problem that we're going to
give as our example
okay so that is the plan
um
i think it's a good time to let's just
take a few questions here
uh to make sure we're all on the same
page as what we're
uh as what we're
doing so let me just read i got a couple
questions already in here
[Music]
so this is a little bit of a side
comment that somebody's asking what's
interesting question basically
is it possible
that
we may not be able to prove
solve the p versus np problem that it's
just
it's not a
problem that one can answer from the
basic axioms in mathematics if i'm
interpreting the question correctly uh
there are certain problems in
mathematics um
you know i think i perhaps i mentioned
earlier in the term the problem of
whether there is a
set
whose size is in between
the integers and the real numbers you
know we know the real numbers are larger
in size than the integers
you know that was our first example of a
diagonalization and is there a problem
of size strictly in between the two
bigger than the integers
smaller than the real numbers so that's
a problem that was
posed a long time ago
it was one of hilbert's problems and was
eventually shown to be
unanswerable
using the basic axioms of mathematics
so the question is maybe p versus np is
in the same category
um
it could be
that could be true of any unsolved
problem in mathematics
but at least our experience has shown
that the kinds of problems that at least
have been shown to be unsolvable
you know from uh mathematical axioms
tend to involve infinities and very
large things things that are very far
from our intuitions
and
something as down to earth as p versus
np at least it would be very surprising
to me if that turned out to be un uh
unanswerable using our our mathematical
axioms but who knows
oh this is another good question do the
time and space
hierarchy theorems have
non-deterministic variants yes they do
they're much harder to prove however
we're not going to cover them but you
can also prove that non-deterministic
time
um
n-cubed properly includes
non-deterministic time n squared you're
not going to be responsible for that
don't worry
if you try to fig if you try to actually
prove that you'll see the
diagonalization
um
doesn't directly work um
and so uh you have to do something
fancier
you know it just uh people are asking
about which reduction method to use you
know
again you know
the kinds of reductions that we
encounter are always very simple so
we're just going to be working with very
weak notions of reductions
not interesting yet generally to
consider powerful kinds of reductions
like
um polynomial exponential time
reductions or things like that so it's
just not something that people really
think about much um
i mean i can talk about it at at length
offline but
let's just assume that our reduction
strength is something very low that log
space is going to be good enough to do
all of the reductions in this class
um
okay so let's move on then um so here's
and
here is the problem that we're going to
spend the next 20 minutes or so proving
to be uh exponential space complete um i
have to do a little introduction first
so
this is this is not the problem but this
is related to the problem so the problem
of testing if two regular expressions
are equivalent
do i just write down two regular
expressions do they generate the same
language
so that problem actually turns out to be
in p space
so it's not going to be exponential
space complete it's actually in p space
i don't think we're going to have to i
thought about presenting it in lecture
it's not that hard to show but it just
took too much time and doesn't really
introduce new methods it's a good
exercise actually using savages there um
but maybe we'll do it in recitation um
or if the lecture
miraculous miraculously ends earlier
i'll do it at the at the end but i don't
think we'll have time
um
so
that's a but that's a setup for
the
intractable problem that we're going to
talk about which is very related
now okay before we get to that so if i
have a regular expression
i'm going to enhance the kind the i'm
going to hand enhance our regular
expression
in one simple way by allowing exponents
or exponentiation
and that means if i regul if i have a
regular expression r
um
i can write r to the k to mean r
concatenated with itself k times sort of
we've been sort of informally using that
all the way along anyway like when we
talk about zero to the k one to the k
um so if we're going to formally allow
that when we write down regular
expressions
in some cases that might allow the
regular expression to be much smaller
especially if we're writing down k in
binary
because i can write r to the million
with just a few symbols
if i have exponentiation
but if i don't have exponentiation then
i have to write r concatenated with r
out a million times and i get a much
much longer and exponentially longer
expression if i don't have that exponent
as a way of describing regular regular
expressions and that's going to make a
big difference
so now the equivalence
a problem for regular expressions with
exponentiation that's what that little
up arrow means
well that signifies
now i'm giving you two regular
expressions but they're allowed to have
x the exponentiation operation
in addition to
the um
standard regular operations
um
so now
testing whether two of these regular
expressions that have exponentiation
that problem turns out to be exponential
space complete
okay
so here's the equivalence problem for
regular expressions with exponentiation
that's an exponential space complete
problem and as we pointed out that means
this problem is provably intractable
so there are
you know there's just no way in general
to solve that problem in polynomial time
that's proven that's known
um
so
we're going to go through the reduction
um i think it's going to be our last
reduction of the term of proving
problems complete for some class
but this one has each one of those has
their own kind of um
thing that makes it special
okay so first of all we have to show
that it's in exponential space and i'm
not that's really going to rely on this
other fact that we didn't prove so i'm
going to go over that very quickly
um but the interesting part is doing the
reduction so if i have something in
exponential space
then i can show that i can reduce it
to the equivalence problem
for regular expressions with
exponentiation
okay so quickly arguing
part one that we're in exponential space
basically what you do is you take your
two regular expressions that you want to
test to see if they're equivalent but
now they have exponentiation and as a
first step you get rid of the
exponentiation
you just expand the things out by
repeating
um the the parts that have the exponents
um
and of course that as i said that's
going to make the expression themselves
exponentially bigger
but now you run the p-space algorithm
on those two exponentially larger
expressions so the input to the p-space
algorithm is now exponential in the
original input size
but it's p-space in that enlarged input
so that's going to give you an
exponential space algorithm in the
original input size
because you know you expanded it to
become exponentially bigger and then you
run the p space algorithm on that
expanded
um
problem
okay
um so that gives you an exponential
space algorithm for
uh for this problem um
but now what we're gonna do
the interesting part is the reduction
so given some language in exponential
space
say decided
by some turing machine in that amount of
space 2 to the n to the k
we're going to give a reduction that
maps a
to
this equivalence problem
got it
that is the plan
so let's make sure we're all together on
the plan before we go ahead and carry
out that plan
so good good you know if you're
got you know we haven't we just sort of
set things up here in a sense um
for what we're going to be doing so
feel free to ask a question on just this
you know the plan
this part has it's going to get
technical because as doing these
reductions always is
there's a simulation involved and you
know you have to kind of
you know describe that simulation in its
own way so now we're going to be
simulating
in a certain sense
m on w
you know the the decider for this
exponential space
problem a
uh we're going to take m on w i'm going
to somehow have to express the fact that
m accepts w using this equivalence
problem for regular expressions with
exponentiation
okay um so no questions why don't we
keep when we move on then
so here's we're gonna we have i have
three slides on this
but they're kind of dense i'm sorry to
say
um
so here is
the plan as usual
um
we're gonna map a
with a polynomial time reduction
to the equivalence problem for regular
expressions with exponentiation
so that means we're going to have to
take an input
which may or may not be an a
and produce two regular expressions
with exponentiation
which are going to be equivalent
when
w is in a
or
when m accepts w
okay
so it's going to be
as these things always are
these are going to be in terms of the
computation history for mnw but in this
case it's going to turn out to be
convenient
convenient
to work with the rejecting
computation history for m on w
so remember
we have a turing machine m
um it's a decider
so that means it always holds
for strings in the language it ends up
at a q accept state for things not in
the language it ends up at a q reject
state
so a rejecting computation history is
the sequence of configurations the
machine goes through
from the start configuration
until it ends up at a configuration with
a reject state a rejecting configuration
okay
and we're going to make a
regular expression that describes all
strings except for that one
it's going to avoid describing a
rejecting computation history for m and
w otherwise it's going to
describe all possible strings
now if m
does not reject w so there is no
rejecting computation history namely m
accepts w by the way so if m accepts w
does not reject w it does not have a
rejecting computation history
what is r one describing
well it's describing in that case
everything
because there is no rejecting
computation history so it's describing
every other string besides
so that means it's describing all
strings
if there is no rejecting computation
history in the case that m accepts w
so what does that suggest we should use
for r2
r2 is going to be the regular expression
that just generates all strings
so we'll be testing whether r1 generates
all strings or not
which is the same as saying does
um m
except w
or not
okay so
r2 is going to be
you know i would like to say sigma star
but sigma is really the input to m so
and gamma is the tape alphabet for m so
we have a lot of greek letters to play
with so we're going to use delta
for the
alphabet
that we write the computation histories
in
and if you want to
get reminded what that delta is
you know a computation history can have
a tape alphabet symbol for m it can have
a state
symbol for m or it can have a delimiter
pound hashtag
so it's either
delta
this capital delta alphabet is a
tape alphabet symbol
or a state
something representing a state symbol or
a hashtag
that's just doubt so don't get you know
i always go i always feel bad if
somebody gets confused by something
that's supposed to be very simple don't
get confused by delta star this is just
all possible strings over the alphabet
delta
okay so what does r1 look so my job is
to do r1 r2 i already told you
r1 now has to describe all those strings
except for the rejecting computation
history
so everything that fails
to be a rejecting computation history so
it fails either because it started wrong
or it ended wrong or it's wrong
somewhere in the middle and by wrong i
mean it
fails to correctly describe the way the
machine operates
if it's ending up rejecting w
right so i'm going to describe all those
possible strings um
you know by breaking it down
in those into those three categories
starts wrong ends wrong or somewhere
computes wrong along the way
okay so
rejecting computation history looks
something like this
you know there's here's the start
configuration
as we you know
you know usually envision it you know
it's a start state looking at the first
symbol of the input and there's the rest
of the input
um so let me just write this out
um
this is a rejecting computation history
now so the start first configuration the
second one and so on and so on until we
end up at a rejecting computation is a
rejecting uh configuration
now
for convenience
i'm going to
uh insist
that all of these configurations are the
same
length
it's going to make my life easier
in doing the proof
because
then why can i do that um well i'm just
gonna take them you know because usually
you think of the configurations they
start small because they're just
basically length in but you know this is
using exponential space they're kind of
getting longer and longer let's just
pair them all out with blanks so that
they're all the same size
so as i've indicated over here we're
adding in a bunch of blanks that's going
to be a lot of blanks here right
to make sure they all have length 2 to
the end of the k which is the maximum
size of a configuration when you have
that much space
um
[Music]
all right
so
um
i'm going to construct so basically
that's my job i'm going to construct r1
so that it generates all all those
strings so i'm sort of wrote a little
box
around that thing i'm trying to that's
that's my
that's my to-do
and i'm also gonna it's gonna help me in
the coming slides because they're a
little bit dense
um
when i'm gonna draw this sort of reddish
pinkish box around something that means
that i'm going to try to describe all
strings except for that one
okay so that that one is um
uh
that's the one you know i
i want to avoid describing that one
because that's the rejecting computation
history but i don't want to describe
everything else that's my that's my
that's my wish
all right um so here's a check-in before
we move forward
but we can also maybe we should just
take some questions even before we
launch the check-in
how are we doing here
so
is our one describing
you know i'm not well r1 is a regular
expression so are we over here we're
talking about a this is just an ordinary
computation history but it ends with a
reject that's all a rejecting
computation history is just one that's a
little different at the end the machine
just ended up projecting instead of
accepting
otherwise everything has to be
you know
um
spelled out
in accordance with the rules of the
machine and the start configuration
um yeah we're assuming if you're in yeah
we're assuming one rejecting
uh
state
yeah that's the way we actually define
turing machines in the first place but
who's arguing yeah there's one there's
one reject state
we're all deterministic correct
um why do we need the padding because i
want to make these all the same size
all of these configurations that's going
to help me later in terms of describing
the invalid configurations the ones that
are not legal configurations legal
rejecting configurations
so just simply a matter of convenience
um but just accept it for now i just
want all of those configurations to be
the same length
in my
uh rejecting computation history
otherwise i'm not going to
you know i'm just encoding that
rejecting computation history in this
particular way um
so people asking about the detail is a
bad start yeah that's yet to come i have
two more slides on this
so i'll tell you about how we're going
to do those
so our bad start
uh that's a good question is our bad
start or all these are all the strings
that don't start this way we'll see it
in a second but our bad start or all the
things that don't start with the
you know they they start bad they
they're they're not a
uh
um they're not starting with the start
configuration uh they're starting with
some other junk
um
do we need only one rejecting
computation history what about the other
ones
you know this is a deterministic machine
so there's only going to be one if i
prescribe the lengths as i've done
there's going to be only one
rejecting computation history because
it's deterministic everything is going
to be forced from the beginning
should r1 be the not of those three
no i'm trying r one is describing all of
the strings except
except
this
uh
this one string so i'm capturing all the
different possible ways a string could
fail
to be the string and he could start
wrong it could be wrong along the middle
somewhere or so i have to union them
together
because i'm disgraced as in
as as i always believe negations are the
most confusing thing to everybody
including me um
so we're
describing all the things that are not
this string
we're trying to stay away from that one
we want to describe everything else
okay oh um
i think i better move on here i got a
lot of questions
talk to the tas
uh
all right check in
how big
is this rejecting computation history
anyway
interesting
there's a lesson here
i got a big burst of answers right at
the very beginning all wrong
but then the bright
the people who took a little bit more
time to think
uh started getting um the right answer
which is
so it's like we got a close election
here and folks though i have to report
i hope we don't have to do a recount
okay come on guys
answer up 10 seconds this is not super
hard
stop the count
yeah i think we better stop it that's
we're
on the edge
um
okay
three seconds
and polling
share results
well
um
the correct answer is in fact c
why is that because each configuration
is 2 to the n to the k
so that's how much space the machine has
exponential space
but the amount of time which is each one
of you know the
the number of configurations is going to
be the amount of time that's used
um is going to be exponentially more
than even than that
so it's going to be 2 to the 2 to the n
to the k
is how many steps the machine can run
and that's going to be how long the
computation history could be
so it's a very long thing
and when you think about it
um the regular expression we are
generating how big is that
the regular expression
and a lot of people playing off my
comments here uh
about
what the votes legal or not okay so
let's focus here so the
um
so this is
doubly exponentially large how big is
the regular expression that we're
generating well that has to be
produced in polynomial time so it's only
polynomially big so we have this
little teensy weensy relatively speaking
regular expression which is only poly
enter the k it's having to describe all
strings except for this this particular
string which is
2 to the 2 to the n to the k
so in a sense this string is that that
you know is related to that regular
expression is doubly exponentially
larger than that and that kind of
presents some of the challenge
in
uh doing the reduction in creating
constructing that regular expression
anyway okay so let's move on and start
doing this is the hard stuff
here is the bad start which is
it challenging enough uh even this
little piece is going to be a little bit
challenging to to describe
so just rewriting what from the previous
uh slide so we're trying to make r1
which is generating all those strings
except the rejecting computation history
frame on w
um it's in those three parts
right now i'm describing the bad start
piece
so that's going to describe all strings
that don't start
with this
c1 so let me write that out here it's
going to generate all strings that don't
start with
c1 c start or c1
which is as as specified looks like this
so any string that doesn't start with
these symbols
doesn't start exactly like this
should be
um
described
by bad start
that regular expression okay so that in
itself is going to be
further subdivided
and the
the reason for that is it's not that
it's not that hard to understand i'm
gonna bad start is gonna
get the
accomplish its goal by saying
well
anything that doesn't start this way
either it doesn't start with a q0 or
doesn't or doesn't have a w1 in the next
place or doesn't have a w2 in the next
place or somewhere along the way it has
a wrong
symbol each one of these guys is going
to be
about
one of those
symbols being wrong in some particular
place
okay so i'm going to show you what those
look like so right now i'm i'm going to
focus my
little um
uh
attention
on
describing all strings except for this
one and then everything you know all
strings that start with with something
except for this one
okay
so just remember delta is the alphabet
for the computation histories
um and there's some notation here delta
sub epsilon we've seen this before is
you're going to add in epsilon as a as
an allowed thing for uh delta so it's
all the symbols or or epsilon that now i
think thought of as a set here
and furthermore
it's going to be convenient to talk
about all the symbols in delta
except for some symbol so like at the
very beginning q0 i want to talk about
all the symbols except for the q0 symbol
because that's what i'm going to be used
to start off
um
you know our bad start it's going to be
anything except for q0
okay so let's just see how that looks
so here is s0 the very first part of our
bad start it's going to say
um i'm trying to color the sort of
the the active ingredient here in in the
pink color
uh so
delta
with q0 removed
followed by anything
so this little regular expression here
describes all strings that don't start
with a q0 so as i'm indicating over here
all strings that don't start with the q0
is what s0 describes so you have to
you have to understand that because it's
just going to build up from there
um
[Music]
so what do we want to say for s1 what's
going to be all strings that don't have
w1 in the second place
so i'm going to write that over here
so
s1 is
anything in the first place
i mean if the first place was wrong s0
took care of it so i'm just going to
keep my lights simple so if all i want
to do is describe all of the thing
places where
the second symbol is wrong namely it's
not w1
so anything in the first place
something besides w1 and this in the
next place
and then
anything at all afterwards those are all
strings that don't have
location so i'll write it over here like
that
now s2 simile's going to take
now i'm going to since i have
exponentiation let's use that for
convenience
um
delta delta or just delta squared
so anything in the first two places
then not w2
in the next place and then anything
so that's going to capture this part so
this is what these different s's do and
you can sort of get the idea so dot dot
this sn is going to describe everything
except for wn
in in that location which is going to be
the n plus first location actually
and now i have to continue on
doing that for the
blanks
so now if you think with me
um
let's just take a look how that's going
could go
so
so now
the next symbol which is
skipping over
the m plus one that i've already taken
care of
i want to say it's not a blank symbol
in this very first location after the
input
so again i'm describing these non these
strings which are not the start
configuration so it's not it could fail
because
it's not there's not a blank where
there's supposed to be a blank
um
and if i do suppose i do that for each
one of these guys
that would work
but
but what
think
this is actually not going to be a good
solution for us
because
there are exponentially many blanks over
here this is a hugely long configuration
and so there's exponentially many blanks
if i do it this way i'm going to end up
with an exponentially large regular
expression and that's not doable in
polynomial time
so i have a more complicated way of
getting the same effect which is i don't
really expect you to fully parse through
this right now in real time in lecture
but let me try to help you what i'm
going to do is
skip over these first initial n plus 1
places
and then a variable number of
places which is indicated by the next
piece here and and the way that works is
so these are all strings of length n
plus one through
the
the the the end of the configuration
um
and to understand that uh
you know it's almost
a little too technical to even try but
let's let's see
if i put delta to the seven that's all
strings of length seven but if i put
delta sub epsilon to the seven if you
think about what that means that's all
strings of length between between 0 and
7.
okay because i can either have an
epsilon in as my
or a symbol from from delta
and so that's what i'm doing over here
i'm getting a variable length space
spacer of deltas
um
that are going to then
end up at a certain location i'm going
to say at that place then i have a
non-blank because all i need to do is
describe the strings that fail to have a
blank somewhere in this range
so i've got to sort of have a kind of a
variable spacer out to that spot
where that missing blank might be
um
okay so that's what this describes
okay if you didn't get that don't worry
uh that is a technical point you can try
to think about it offline
and then at the very very end i'm going
to describe uh what happens make sure
that you know describe the strings that
fail to have a pound sign a hashtag in
that location
how i
describe all strings that don't start
right
okay that's a lot of work just to do
that little piece
uh fourthly the next two pieces are
easier
surprisingly
okay so
um you can jump in with a question um
but
uh maybe i should move push on um
so now i'm going to describe the bad
move and bad reject pieces um
and bad reject generates all strings
that don't contain the str the q reject
symbol
so that's going to certainly describe
all of the uh strings that don't end
correctly
and that's just simply
uh
the delta with the q reject symbol
removed
and then any string of those so that's
all strings that don't have q reject so
that's going to describe all strings uh
that um
don't end with a q reject plus some
other junk strings along the way but
that's all that's all
never
a problem to put in other strings that
you're going to might be capturing in
some some other part of the regular
expression that you know of bad strings
you just want to make sure you don't put
in that one uniquely good string which
is the rejecting computation history
and lastly
um we're going to use the notion of the
neighborhoods
this might be you might think this is
the hardest part but in fact not that
hard so these are all of the um
the strings that have somewhere along
the way
um
a violation
uh according to m's rules you want to
describe all of those as well i'm going
to do that in terms of the neighborhoods
but the neighborhoods now are going to
be
stretched out
they're not not you know we don't have a
tableau anymore so they're not
so easily visualizable but it's the same
idea the neighborhood so this is abc and
def but now it's an illegal neighborhood
def does not follow from abc
if all the neighborhoods are legal then
the whole
competition is
is a legitimate computation provided it
starts and ends correctly
so if it's not a legitimate computation
there's got to be an illegal
neighborhood somewhere and i'm going to
just describe all strings that have an
illegal neighborhood
and the interesting part is you have to
describe you have to place that
separator
between abc and def
so this is another place where we're
going to critically use the
exponentiation um
to
uh
and and the fact that all the
configurations are the same length
that's where we we're using that we know
exactly how far apart the bottom of the
2x3 neighborhood is from the top of the
2x3 neighborhood okay so we're going to
take a union over all
illegal 2x3 neighborhoods
neighborhood settings i should say and
there's only a fixed number of those for
the same reason that we had in the cook
eleventh theorem there's a fixed number
of those depending upon the machine
and now we're gonna have say we're gonna
start with anything
here's the top of the neighborhood here
is the separator that separates the top
from the bottom in the two consecutive
configurations here see i
going to see i plus one
inside my computation history
and then after that uh separator i put
in the the second part of the
neighborhood which is the def
okay
it's a little bit yeah you have to
really be comfortable with
the way we've been presenting these
other uh reductions up until now if to
really get this so
um anyway i think we're at the break
um
so we can just take questions uh during
the break if you have any
and um
i will otherwise uh see you in five
minutes
you know in my description back here so
let me just take this off um
um
for
bad reject uh it looks like i'm doing
kind of overkill and maybe doing
something wrong here i'm describing all
strings that don't never reject anywhere
but as long as i don't describe
the legitimate rejecting computation
history
i do describe all strings that don't end
correctly
um
i'm good
i could go through more effort
to make sure that i'm only describing
the very last configuration here
as being as not having the reject but
you know
[Music]
that would just be
more work and i don't need to do that
work so maybe it would be good just
understand why this is sufficient what
i've described here and it's not going
to cause me any problems
um
okay some
i'm getting a note from my uh from one
of my tas thomas
saying that the notion bad perhaps is
confusing because bad sounds like
rejecting
yes
i mean bad in the sense of not
describing a legal uh computation
history if you can think of another name
i'm happy to switch that for
future years
too late for now but yeah i don't mean
that rejecting i mean that it's not just
not it's ill it you know it's
i don't know what the right term is
illegal um
or
i i'm not sure what a good how are the
neighborhoods defined here what is the
tableau here
i think you do need to think about it
after lecture but um
the the tableau you can think of the
tableau now here just written out
linearly
they're all of the rows now instead of
nicely organized into a table they're
just appeared consecutively because i'm
just trying to describe i need to do it
to describe a string whether my regular
expression doesn't really make sense to
think about i mean you can fold it up
into a tableau if you like and then and
then abc and def will just line up but
here if you think about them written
consecutively this is exactly how far
apart they end up being
um
[Music]
are there only polynomially many illegal
neighborhoods
so we have to know that that's why i
kind of corrected myself it's not
illegal neighborhoods that we're told
because there the number of
neighborhoods in this picture is vast
but the neighbor number of neighborhood
settings
the way to set these values to abcdef
and there's only
i mean these are symbols that can appear
in the
in a configuration um
uh of the machine so these are there's
only a
fixed number of symbols that can appear
here um
that depend upon the the the definition
of the machine so it's not only
polynomial there's a constant number
of these things that only uh only the
depends on the machine so yeah you have
to think about what's going on i there's
a lot
this is a lot in the slide i
um
it history for reject it's a bad history
for rejecting somebody's suggesting
yeah
it's a bad history
what is
fake news maybe we should be fake fake
would be a good term nah that's not so
good i don't know um
yeah two by three the reason two by
three is two by three is the right so
somebody's asking why two by three two
by three is exactly the size as you need
to to say that if all the two by three
neighborhoods are correct everywhere in
the
computation history
then the whole history is going to be
consistent with the rules of m it's
going to be a legal representation of a
computation of m
um so if the string
which is
allegedly a computation history
has a bad neighborhood somewhere a bit
2x3 neighborhood somewhere then um well
if it's not a legal computation history
it's got to have a bad um
neighborhoods two by three neighborhoods
somewhere
anyway
um
okay let's move on um
to uh because i think we're out of time
here um
uh
our timer is up
five we're gonna
shift gears now anyway so if you got a
little lost
in the previous proof we're gonna talk
about something different and in some
ways a little bit i think a little
lighter less technical and that's about
oracles
okay so um
okay
what are oracles organs are a simple
thing um
but they're they're in a useful concept
uh for a number of reasons um
and
especially because they they're gonna
tell us something interesting about
methods which may or may not be useful
for proving the p versus mp question
when someday somebody hopefully does
that
so um what is an oracle
an oracle is free information you're
going to give to a turing machine which
might affect um the difficulty of
solving problems
and the way we're going to represent
that free information is
we're going to allow the turing machine
to test membership in some specified
language
without
charging
for
for that for the work involved
so um
i'm going to allow you to have any
language at all some language a and say
a turing machine with an oracle for a
is it isn't
written this way m with a superscript a
it's a machine that has a black box that
can answer questions is some string
which the machine can choose
in a or not
and it gets that answer
in one step effectively for free
um
[Music]
so you can imagine depending upon the
language that you're providing to the
machine
that may or may not be useful
so
for example suppose i give you an oracle
for the sat language
that can be very useful
it could be very useful for deciding sat
for example because now you don't have
to go through a brute force search to
solve sat you just ask the oracle and
the oracle is going to say
yes it's satisfiable or no it's not
satisfied
but you can use that to
to solve other languages too
quickly
because anything that you can do in np
you can reduce the sat so you can
convert it to a sad question which you
can then ship up to the oracle and the
oracle is going to tell you the answer
so then you know the word oracle already
sort of conveys something magical
we're not really going to be concerned
with the operation of the oracle so
don't ask me how does the oracle work or
what does it correspond to in reality it
doesn't it's just a mathematical device
which provides this free information to
the turing machine which enables it to
compute certain things
it turns out to be a useful concept
that's used in cryptography where you
might imagine the oracle could could
provide the factors to some number or
the password or to some system or
something free information and then what
can you do with that
so this is a notion that comes up in
other places
um
so
if we have a
an oracle
we can think of all of the things that
you can compute in polynomial time
relative to that oracle so that's what
we um
the terminology people usually use
sometimes called relativization or
computation relative to having this
extra information so p
with an a oracle is all of the language
that you can decide in polynomial time
if you have an oracle for a
um
[Music]
let's see
yeah if somebody's asking me is it
really free or does it cost one unit you
know it's even just setting up the
oracle and writing down the question to
the oracle is going to take you some
number of steps so you're not going to
be able to do an infinite number of
oracle calls in in zero time so charging
one step or zero steps not going to make
a difference because still have to
formulate the question
um
so
uh
the
as i pointed out p with a sad oracle so
all the things you do in polynomial time
with this satellite includes np
does it perhaps include other stuff
or are they or does it equal np
um
would have been a good check-in question
but i'm not going to ask that
the uh in fact it seems like it contains
other things too because cohen p
is also contained within
p
given a sad oracle
because
the sad article answers both yes or no
depending upon the the answer
so if the formula is unsatisfiable the
oracle is going to say no it's not in
the language
and now so you can do the complement of
the sat problem as well the
unsatisfiability problem so you can do
all of co and p in the same way
you can also define np
relative to some oracle so all the
things you can do in with a
non-deterministic turing machine where
all of the branches have separately
access
and they can ask multiple questions by
the way of the oracle
um
independently
um
so let's take let's do another a little
bit of a more challenging example uh the
main formula language which i hope you
remember from your homework
so those are all of the formulas
that do not have a shorter equivalent
formula
they are minimal
you cannot make a smaller formula that's
equivalent that gives you the same
boolean function
um
so you showed for example that that
language is in
uh p space as i recall
and there was some other yet another two
problems about that language um
the complement of the min formula
problem
is an np with a sad oracle
so mull that over for a second and then
we'll see why
[Music]
and that's because
here's an algorithm an np an an np with
a sad oracle
algorithm
so um
so in other words now i want to i
you know though
i want to kind of
implement that strategy which i argued
in the homework problem was not legal
but now that i have the sad oracle it's
going to turn make it possible where
before it was no was not possible
um
so let's just understand what i
mean by that
uh
so
if i'm trying to
uh do the
the non-minimal formulas namely the
formulas that do have a shorter
equivalent uh
uh uh formula
um so
i'm gonna guess that sort of formula
called psi
and now
the
the challenge before was testing whether
that shorter formula was actually
equivalent to fee
because that's not obviously doable in
polynomial time
but the equivalence problem for formulas
is a cohen p problem
or if you'd like to think about it the
other way any formula in equivalence is
an np problem because you just have to
the witness is the assignment on which
they disagree
so two formulas are equivalent if they
never disagree
and so that's a co-np problem
okay so a sad oracle can solve a coin
problem namely the equivalence of the
two formulas the input formula and the
one that you not deterministically
guessed
and if it turns out that they are
equivalent
a smaller formula is equivalent to the
input formula you know the input formula
is not minimal
and so you can accept
and if it gets the wrong formula it
turns out not to be equivalent um then
you reject on that branch of the
non-determinism just like we did before
and if the formula really was minimal
there's not going to be none of the
branches is going to find a shorter
equivalent formula
so
that's why this problem here is in np
with a sad oracle
okay so now i'm gonna we're gonna try to
investigate this on my uh we're getting
near the end of the of the lecture we're
gonna look at the um
you know problems like well
um
suppose i compare p with a sad oracle
and np with a sad oracle
could those
be the same
well there's reasons to believe those
are not the same
but
could there be any
a
where p with an a oracle
is the same as np with an aortal it
seems like no
but actually that's wrong
there is a language there are languages
for which np with that oracle and p
with that oracle are exactly the same
and then and that actually is an
interest it's not just a curiosity it
actually has relevance to
strategies for solving p versus np
um
which hopefully i'll have time to get to
um
can we think of an oracle like a hash
table
i think hashing is somehow different in
spirit
of sort of
um
i understand there's sort of some
similarity there but i don't see that
hashing is a way of um
uh you know finding a sort of a short
name
for for objects
um
which has a variety of different
purposes why you might want to do that
and so i don't really think it's the
same uh let's see in an oracle question
okay let's see how do we use sat oracle
to solve where the two formulas are
equivalent
so okay let's getting back to this point
how can we use the satellite oracle to
solve whether two formulas are
equivalent
well we can use a sad oracle to solve
any np problem
because it's reducible to sad
right you know in in other words if
p
you know with a sad oracle contains all
of np so you have to make sure you
understand that part
um
uh
but you know like if you have like the
clique problem you can reduce if i give
you a clique problem which is an np
problem
and i want to use the oracle
to
test if the formula if the graph has a
clique
i reduce that problem to a sad problem
using the cook leaven theory
and knowing that a clique of a certain
size is going to correspond to having a
formula which is satisfiable now i can
ask the oracle
and if i can do np problems i can do
co-np problems because p
is a deterministic class even though it
has an oracle it's still deterministic
it can invert the answer
something that non-deterministic
machines cannot necessarily do
okay so i don't know maybe that's
let's move on um
so there's an oracle where p
to the a equals np to the a which kind
of seems like
kind of amazing at some level because
here's an oracle where the
non-determinism if i give you that
oracle non-determinism non-determinism
doesn't help
um
and it's actually a language we've seen
it's tqbf
why is that well here's the whole proof
if i have an np with a tqbf oracle
let's just check each of these steps
i claim i can do that
with a
non-deterministic polynomial space
machine
which
that no longer has in oracle
the reason is that if i have polynomial
space
i can answer questions about tqbf
without needing an oracle i have enough
space just to answer the question
directly myself
and i use my non-determinism here to
simulate the non-determinism of
the np machine so every time the np
machine now
you know branches now deterministically
so do i every time one of those branches
asks the oracle a tqbf question i just
do my polynomial space algorithm to
solve that question myself
but now np space equals p space by
savage is there
and because tqbf
is piece based complete
for the very same reason
that
a sad oracle allows me to do every np
problem a tqbf problem allows me to do
every piece based problem
and so i get
np contained within p for tqbf oracle
and of course
you get the containment the other way
immediately
so they're equal
what does that have to do
with
um
[Music]
uh somebody said
you know
i'll i'll just i don't want to run out
of time so i'll take any questions at
the end
um
what has this got to do with the p
versus empty problem
okay so this is an actual this is a very
interesting connection
um
and
uh
so
you know remember
we just showed
through a combination of today's lecture
and yesterday's lecture uh and
and um
uh
uh i guess thursday's lecture
that
this problem this equivalence problem is
not in p space and therefore it's not in
p and therefore it's intractable
right we just that's what we just did
um
[Music]
we showed it's complete for a class
which is provably outside of p
probably bigger than p
um
well that's what that's the kind of
thing we would like to be able to do to
separate p and np we would like to show
that some other problem is not in p
some other problem is intractable namely
sat if we could do sat
then we're good
we've we've sal p and np
so we already have an example
of being able to do that could we use
the same method
um which is something people did try to
do many years ago to show that sat is
not in p
so what is that method really well that
method the guts of that method really
comes from the hierarchy theorem that's
where you're actually proving problems
are hard you're getting this problem
with the through the hierarchy
uh construction that's provably
um outside of p space
or and outside of p
um that's a diagonalization and if you
and you look carefully at what what's
going on there um so we're going to say
no
we're not going to be able to self-set
show stats outside of p in the same way
and the reason is suppose we could
um well the hierarchy theorems are
proved by diagonalization
and
you know
what i mean by that is
that
in the hierarchy theorem there's a
machine d which is simulating some other
machine m
so
um to remember what's going on there
remember that we made a machine
which is going to make its language
different from the language of every
machine that's running with less space
or with less time
right that's how d
was defined
it wants to make sure its language
cannot be done
in
in less space so it makes sure that its
language is different that it doesn't it
simulates the machines that use less
space and does something different from
what they do
well that
simulation um
if
we had an oracle
if we're trying to show that um
you know if we provide both the
simulator and the machine being
simulated with the same oracle the
simulation still works
every time the machine you're simulating
um
asks a question the simulator has the
same oracle so it can also ask the same
question
and can still do the simulation
so in other words if you could prove p
different from np
using basically a simulation which is
what what a diagonalization is
then you would be able to prove that p
is different from np for every oracle
so if you can prove p different mnp by a
diagonalization that would also
immediately prove that p is different
from np for every oracle
because the or the the the argument is
transparent to the oracle
if you just put the oracle down
everything still works
but
here is the big but
um
it can't be
that um we we know that p
a is
that we know this is false we just
exhibited an oracle for which they're
equal
it's not the case that p is different
from np for every oracle
sometimes they're equal for so many
oracles
so something that's just a basically a a
very straightforward diagonalization to
you know something that's at its core is
a diagonalization is not going to be
enough to solve p and np because
otherwise it would prove that they're
different for every oracle and and
sometimes they're not different for some
oracles so that that that's
you know
that's an important insight for what
kind of in the method will not be
adequate
to prove p different from np and this
comes up all the time
um you know people who are make proposed
hypothetical solutions that they're
trying to show p different from np one
of the very first things people ask is
well would that argument still work
um if you put an oracle there
and um
often it does which
points out there was a flaw
um anyway uh last check-in
so this is just a little test of your
knowledge about oracle's um
why don't we in our remaining minute
here
uh
let's say 30 seconds and then
we'll we'll we'll do a wrap on this and
i'll
point out which ones are right oh boy
we're all over the place of this one
uh
it is
you're liking them all looks well i
guess the one
the
the ones that are false are lagging
slightly
um
okay
um
okay let's let's conclude
um
did i
did i give you enough time there i share
results
um
uh so in fact um
uh
um
yeah so
having the an oracle for the compliment
is the same as having an oracle so the
this is certainly true
np said equal cohen p said
we have no reason to believe that would
be true and
we
we don't know it to be true so this is b
is
not a not a good choice then that's the
laggard here min formula
um
well is in p space and anything in p
space isn't
reducible to dq bf so this is certainly
true
and
same thing for np with tqbf and cohen p
with the tqbf once you have tqbf um
you're going to get
all of um
a p space and as we pointed out you're
going to this is gonna be cool as well
um
so uh why don't we end here
and i think we're this is the that
that's my last slide so oh no there's my
summary here this is what we've done
and i will uh
send you all off on your way um
how does the interaction between the
turing machine and the oracle look yeah
i didn't define exactly how the machine
interacts with an oracle you can imagine
having a separate tape where writes the
oracle question and then goes into a
special query state
you know you can formalize it however
you like they're all going to be any
reasonable way of formalizing it is
going to be
come up with the same notion in the end
um
it does show that p with a tqbf oracle
equals p space yes that is correct good
point
why do we need the oracle to be tqbf
wouldn't sat also work because it could
solve any np problem so you're asking
does p with a sad oracle equal np with a
sad oracle not known and and not
believed not to be true but we don't
don't have a compelling reason for that
but uh no one has any idea how to do
that because for example you know we
showed the um
uh the
complement of min formula
is an np with a sad oracle
um
but no one knows how to do because
there's sort of two levels of
non-determinism there there's guessing
the smaller formula and then guessing
again to check the uh equivalence
and they really can't be combined
because one of them sort of exit an
exist type guessing the other one is
kind of a for all type guessing
um
and so uh that's
no one knows how to do that in
polynomial time with the sad oracle
so
it generally believed that they're not
the same
um
in the check and why was b false b was
um
is
the same question does np
with the sat oracle equal coin p with a
sad oracle
i'm not saying it's false it's just not
known to be true
if you can
you know it doesn't follow from anything
that we've shown so far
and i think you know that would be
something that um
well i i guess it doesn't immediately
imply any famous open problem
so
you know uh i wouldn't necessarily you
wouldn't expect you to know that it's an
unsolved problem but it is
um
okay
could we have oracles for undecidable
languages absolutely
would it be helpful well if you're
trying to solve a solvent undecidable
problem it would be helpful
but people do study that
you know in fact the original concept of
oracle's
was um
presented in the um what was derived in
the compute computability theory
um
and a side note
you can talk about reducibility that i
don't want to go there too complicated
but um
what is not known to be true
again um
what is not known to be true is that np
with a sad oracle equals
cohen p with the sad oracle or equals p
with the sad oracle
nothing is known except the obvious
relations among those those are all on
unknown and just not known to be true
or false
um
is np with a sad oracle equal to np
probably not np with a sad oracle for
one thing contains cohen and p
because it's even more powerful we
pointed out that p with a certain oracle
contains with it it contains coin p
and so np with the satellite is going to
be at least as good
and so
it's going to contain cohen p and so
probably not going to be equal to np
unless
shockingly unexpected things happen in
our complexity world
you